[Music]
i'd like to solve the puzzle
russ wilson no andy dalton and the
reaction yes that's chicago bears
quarterback andy dalton sorry folks in
chicago
they really didn't try to get him but
they want you to think that
they did which doesn't belong and why
speaking of
a bears quarterback who surely will be a
former bears quarterback
these are potentially available signal
callers which doesn't belong and why
mitchell trubisky alex smith gardner
minshew
i'm going to go with alex smith you know
i look at mitch trubisky and gardiner
menchu and go
man you get them you got a really good
backup quarterback
alex smith i mean as we've talked about
it scares me i don't know if i'd really
want him as my backup quarterback and i
don't mean that any disrespect to him
but you know the way he looked at the
end of the year that leg all of that
we've talked about it a lot to me he's
the guy that doesn't belong
i say trubisky doesn't belong because i
think he's the starter of the three the
guy that i think is going to be
somewhere when the dust settles starting
maybe not week one
but i think he's going to be he's going
to be starting this year and chris i
think your guy kyle shanahan at some
point is going to realize that that may
be his best option as the number two to
jimmy garoppolo well i can see the
possibility of
of being the number one if they squeeze
garoppolo to take less and he says
no thank you or if garoppolo gets hurt
uh not exactly a stretch given that he's
missed 23 games over the last three
years hey i i hear you there i mean that
that does make sense to me
i mean trubisky would fit that shanahan
mold as far as what he wants at a
quarterback and
you know at the very least trubisky
you know is better than what people want
to give him credit for he is better than
what you want to give him credit for and
there's no doubt there's been moments to
where you go okay that's pretty good
football
you know he has played in two playoff
games one of which he played pretty damn
good and and they should have won
against the eagles and the double doing
so you know yeah that's i'm good for you
for talking about him and giving a
little
little props i'm sick of everybody
crapping on him all the time
two playoff appearances in three seasons
yeah i know
i'll take that right uh all right pass
rusher's coming off of a career year
leonard williams of the giants hassan
reddick now of the panthers
trey hendrickson now of the bengals
which doesn't belong in a while well
i'll go with hassan reddick
really and just from a pure football
thing like the other two guys are true
defensive lineman i'm interested to see
what carolina's gonna do with hassan
reddick
you know first off carolina's got you
know
brian burns who's a legit pass rusher
off the edge first round pick
you know remember last year they took
eater gross mottos from penn state in
the second round
he's gonna be a force on the edge too to
where
i just want to know what you know hassan
riddick's going to do
i would imagine he plays some stand-up
linebacker
with maybe um thompson shaq thompson in
the middle
and then maybe in nickel and dime
situations he gets on the edge a little
bit
uh but i'm interested to see how they
play him and how that works and of
course he's you know going back with his
old college coach and matt rule
i think leonard williams doesn't belong
because he's clearly the best of the
bunch it's that simple he's that he's a
the established guy even though last
year was a career year he's the guy you
can count on the most likely continue
good point i like success yes all right
receivers who have signed who are under
the age of 27
corey davis of the jets curtis samuel of
washington richard higgins
who signed a one-year deal to stay with
the browns which doesn't belong and why
well i'll go with him richard higgins is
the guy that does it
i think he's kind of on a one-year prove
it type of deal a little bit
you know samuel corey davis you know
those are those
high-end number twos maybe even a low
number one for some teams in football
and things like that
higgins is a clear number two that will
probably have to be a number three with
odell and jarvis landry
but you know he's finding the angle the
team's gonna be good
i've carved out a little roll who knows
how healthy obj
is coming back and all that and i think
he signed the deal going you know what
i'm gonna have another good year like i
did last year and try to strike it rich
next year
and he clearly wanted to come back to
the browns he said within the last two
weeks on a radio interview hey call me
make me an offer that's not exactly the
way you build your maximum leverage
to get your best possible package but he
got what he wanted he got an offer and
he's back with the browns yeah
uh available receivers over 30. antonio
brown
t.y hilton desean jackson which doesn't
belong and why and it's amazing
that that those guys are available and i
know it's not 2014 anymore but still
these are guys who have accomplished
some great things in the nfl which
doesn't belong in one i'm going to go
with t-y
just because he's the guy with the least
amount of questions in my opinion
you know i still think there's good play
there you know ty missed one game last
year you know i think he battled through
some injuries playing two last year and
he wasn't totally healthy in all those
games
you know the year before that i think he
missed you know four or five games
but for the most part he's been a
dependable
you know player at the wide receiver
position and i still think has
gas in the tank to contribute to a
football team as a
a number two receiver and all that
desean jackson would scare the hell out
of me
you know just the injuries themselves
he's a cheetah and i mean that you know
in a respectful way it's just he
he can fly but when they pull a muscle
or do something like that
all of a sudden they can't chase
gazelles anymore so that worries me and
of course antonio brown
uh i mean there's always questions there
i mean
can he can he work without tom brady i
don't know
in my mind he's the one who doesn't
belong and here's why he's clearly the
most talented of the three
he's managed to stay out of trouble for
most of the last year he's been
nowhere to be seen on social media
unless there's been something the last
day or so but i've been very intrigued
by this
possibility that someone else is going
to eventually sign antonio brown because
he has a super bowl ring
they kept chris godwin who knows where
he fits on the depth chart in tampa
he could fit higher on the depth chart
somewhere else and you know what if
there is a chance that larry fitzgerald
and tom brady team up in tampa that's
antonio brown's spot
yeah that goes to larry fitzgerald so i
i'm very intrigued by what nathaniel
brown can do
if he truly has turned the corner and
and gotten past some of those
ridiculous behaviors that plagued him
throughout 2019 and into early
2020. uh all right available corners
over the age of 30 richard sherman
malcolm butler xavier rhodes which
doesn't belong and why
this is a tough one here i i think the
guy i'm going to go with
is richard sherman you know and and the
fact of
just the age of richard sherman and
you know the recent injury history the
other guys don't have that yeah malcolm
butler didn't live up to all the
expectations of the tennessee titans i
get that xavier rhodes yeah he fizzled
out with the vikings
you know played solid football last year
nothing special
richard's you know it's a dicey decision
you know i don't the accomplishments hey
that's all great and everything like
that but he barely played last year
of course he tore his achilles tendon
the year before the super bowl up with
the seattle seahawks so you got that so
you got
two you know significant years of
injuries
out of the last three years and then
that one good year
with the 49ers was good but over
inflated i mean come on
i mean it's it's overinflated the
defense was awesome
it's one of the best defenses we saw in
the last 20 years of football
it arguably had one of the best pass
rushes we've seen in the last 20 years
of football
it's real it's it's easier to play
corner when the quarterback can only
hold the ball for 1.5 seconds
so that's the guy i got the most
questions about here i think out of that
group
i agree with you and look i don't want
to be a jerk i just want to say facts
um robert sala is the current coach of
the jets he's implementing his system in
new york and i said before we got to
free agency if robert sala is not at the
front of the line
to sign richard sherman that is the
reddest red flag that we could have
heading into whether or not other teams
should want to sign richard sherman
because salah is the one who should want
him
salah is the one who should be saying
richard
let's go do this thing in new york and
the fact that that there's been crickets
in that regard the saints the only team
linked
to richard sherman so far because of the
connection to chris richard from years
ago inside battle
it's not promising too with him wasn't
there
nothing's happened yeah well that was
john gruden blatantly tampering
but uh either that scared gruden away or
they just you know part of it is part of
it and
see here's the thing the teams deal with
this every year
the players deal with it once or twice
in their careers but i think the teams
recognize for certain guys
you just have to let time pass so they
can work through
the reality that they're not going to
get what they think they're worth yeah
that's right
right and i think that may be part of it
whether it's juju smith schuster or
richard sherman
you got to let some time pass so they
work through anger denial bargaining
depression
and rest on acceptance all right one
more running backs on a new team which
doesn't belong and why
mark ingram with the texans marlon mack
back with the colts jamal williams
jumping from the packers to the lions i
i'll go with marlon mack from the the
fact that one he is still with the same
team and two
to me he's the guy that i still look at
and go no he
he can be a number one running back
still you know he if he's
he's not going to be with jonathan
taylor but like there's legitimate juice
left in the tank with marlon mack and he
is a legitimate starter mark ingram you
know end of the career
jamal williams i think is you know a
really good backup to have as a running
back i look at marlon mack yeah he's
going to be a backup but he's got
starter talent
i look at jamal williams though well you
know what they have deandre swift yeah
i know they're they're they're like
they're they're roping for
where's our number one they got the kid
from auburn still who's been injured too
and i'm oh you know i'm boring carry on
johnson yes exactly right yeah he's
still there too which is
i know when they signed adrian peterson
last year they were concerned about
carrion johnson yeah
and we saw peterson end up getting a lot
of work i'll go with you i think marlon
mack
and it's a shame that he couldn't find
anything anywhere else but it's the torn
achilles weak one
that's right and the fact that the
running black market just doesn't
doesn't bear a ton of fruit for even
great running backs i remember there was
a time a few years ago jim irsay was
touting marlon mack as an 1800 yard guy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports